Welcome to English in a Minute, where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
Have you ever heard someone say,...
What's up?
Let's take a look at this conversation.
Hey, what's up?
What's up?
How are you?
I'm doing fine, thanks.
This phrase is a casual expression and is normally used when you're talking to friends,...
...family, or colleagues.
You would not want to use it in a formal business situation.
"What's up?" is a greeting.
It's a different way of saying "What's happening?".
When you ask someone, "What's up?" in a conversation,...
...it's another way to say hello, ask how things are going, how the person is feeling.
It's a common greeting used by just about everybody in America.
And that's English in a Minute.